Intentionally making a product selection for your personal use surrounding whether
something has a bug bounty program or not, not only pays dividends from a security perspective,
but also can pay actual dividends for you to get bounties. That's great.
Yeah, man, I wish my jumper was here.
My sweater.
Sweater. Why do you say it with an American accent? Can you say sweater? Did you not say sweater at all?
Sweater.
Sweater. That's it. Got it. Got it.
Every time.
All right, man. All right. Cool. Well, today, everybody, we have critical thinking's own
Brandon right here, our writer for the Hacker Notes. And I'm excited for this episode because
I've wanted to have Brandon on for a while because I think his story is really good.
And it's amazing to me to see how much progress has been made in 10 months as of today, actually,
of working together and having a mentorship type thing. But to be honest, most of the time, it's
just me being like, yeah, that's right. Continue doing that. That sounds great to me. So Brandon,
I'll give you an opportunity here to give us a little bit of self-history. And then also,
as I'm reading over this document, I'm realizing that I think we have a little bit of a different
story on how we met originally. So I'm interested to hear your take and then tell mine.
Sure. So in terms of background and experience, I started in cyber when I was 16. So 10 years now,
which has been a very wild and long career so far. If I start going gray soon, that's probably why,
but it's been good. I started off very much in a blue team in system administration.
Stuff always with the goal of wanting to be a pen tester and wanted to go into pen testing.
So throughout that progress and throughout that career, I grinded out certs because that's what
I believe was the only way to get there, but more on that later. And I've been testing for the past
six years now and started bug hunting 10 months ago. So it's been an interesting journey and lots
to talk about, but you can't fit 10 years into 10 minutes.
No, you can't, man. And actually I was kind of surprised to hear that it was, it was, you know,
10 years that you've been, you've been at it now. And I was like, oh man, he's been, he's been at this
for quite a while. And then I'm realizing, yeah, I've also been, I've been doing this for,
for 16 years. I've, I started like hacking stuff when I was like 12, dude.
That's insane.
And so it's crazy how, how much, how much time it takes, but it makes a lot of, it, it, it makes
sense to me that it, that you progressed so much faster than a lot of the other people in the bug
bounty industry that I've seen given how, how focused you've been on pen testing. And I think
also you were a pen tester even before we started, you know, training and stuff together. But yeah,
that makes a, that makes a lot more sense. And then, okay. So, so it says here in the notes that,
that did you suggest that you be a writer for critical thinking or did I suggest that?
Uh, so I suggested that.
Really? Okay.
So I'll give you my, I'll give you my context and how I thought this started.
Okay.
So the hacker notes originally from my context started off in my iPhone and I have a lot of
like nonsensical scribbles, voice notes, memos, all of it, uh, which basically highlighted the key
takeaways from each episode, which I found useful and which I thought other hackers would find useful
as well. And it got to a point where I was like, I'm doing this for myself, but other people might
like benefit from this. Yeah.
And then this is sort of tied into the whole me messaging you and reaching out and going, Hey,
um, I'm doing this thing called the hacker notes. Um, I'm looking for mentorship. If I'd done this for
the pods, would you provide mentorship? See how it goes. And I was expecting to be ignored. I'm not
going to lie. I was not expecting a response at all. And you responded a couple of days later.
And this was over Christmas. I think when I reached out.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And, um, I was like, wow. Okay. And then we, me, you and Joel jumped on the call
and then, uh, off it went really. We gave the hack and I was a guy and it went quite well.
Yeah. Yeah, dude. Okay. So that it must've just been perfect timing because I, I remember also
getting some advice from a respected podcaster, you know, saying, Hey, you, you have to get somebody
to, to write notes for your, for your podcast. Like there has to be a text version because, um, you know,
you're doing the video thing, you're doing the audio thing. It just makes sense to also have text.
Right. And because some people, you know, there's a various different ways for people to consume media.
Um, so I was thinking about it. I think at the time in our, our writer, you know, had moved along
and I, and I was like, I really got to find someone else. So I think you just kind of like
hit the nail on the head. Uh, when, when you asked, I was like, yeah, that's exactly what we need.
I, I, I accept, you know, um, it's funny because the actual message
that sat in my notes for a while. Cause I was like, how do I position this? So I'm not like
some creep from the internet, but also sounds good enough that you would respond back. So it sat in
my notes for like a good couple of days with like various iterations. And then I got to the point
where I thought, no, I'm just going to send it and see how it goes.
Well, well, clearly it worked, man. Clearly it worked. And since there has been one other individual
who has, has successfully pulled off this, um, I'll provide services for mentorship sort of thing.
Um, I'm just going to go ahead and put it out there. I am not open to that arrangement right now.
I'm so sorry. Like I, I just can't do, Brandon's too much of a handful. I can't, I can't take on any
more mentees. Um, but yeah, I, I think it's been really fun too. And we, you know, in our meetings,
we've kind of been talking recently, the way we have it structured for, for, for the listeners is,
um, is, you know, once a week we'll meet up and we'll kind of do a sync for like,
you know, 30 minutes to an hour on what's, what's going on in the bug bounty stuff for this past,
you know, week or whatever, what kind of strategies we're using, you know,
if you've got any technical questions, that sort of thing. Um, and yeah, I mean, it's,
it's gone incredibly well and it's been really exciting to see how you've grown and, uh, also,
you know, just kind of debrief along the way, because a lot of this has just been a,
like a straight upward trajectory. There hasn't been a lot of, you know, hills and hills and stuff. So,
um, yeah. What do you, what do you think about that whole experience? Um,
what, what are some, some takeaways or some thoughts you've had from that mentorship
process that just give, give, give a brother a grade here? Like what kind of stuff was helpful
and what kind of stuff wasn't helpful? Well, what's funny now, looking back with the context I have
on you now, which I didn't have before when I used to report stuff and either get downgraded by
triage or not understood or anything like that. I would just be raging in our discord, like,
what's going on? It's been downgraded. Like what? And just being so like fiery and angry. And you
guiding me through the emotional side of bug bounty was very valuable because my default was to just get
really annoyed for not much reason actually. And now I realize how busy you are and how structured
everything is. You must've just been looking at your discord thinking, Oh no, why have I taken him?
I, no, no, dude. I've, I've been there, man. I've been there and it's, it's really frustrating. You
know, I think there aren't really a lot of industries that I can think of that are results,
you know, money for results, right? Like, like, um, like book bounty is. So if you are delivering
something that you perceive to be a high quality result and expecting to get paid for it, you know,
and, and then it, it doesn't happen, that's extremely demoralizing and infuriating, right?
Especially when you have put so much time and effort into our POCs, into our, our reports like we do.
Right. So I think, I think that, that, that's an interesting thing that you pointed out as, as one of
the top, uh, you know, pieces of, of information you've pulled away from our mentorship is, is that whole,
like emotional regulation and, um, you know, I, I guess there's also that aspect of knowing
what kind of things you can say back to triagers and, and that it's not like nail in the coffin.
I just lost my bounty. It's let's have a conversation, right?
Mm-hmm .
That's it. Yeah. That, and it's funny because even though I've been on the other side of the fence
with bug bounty in the triage position, managing quite small programs until you've actually reported
stuff as a hunter, you can't recreate that emotional, like rollercoaster or that context
or anything like that. You have to really go out, do it, experience it, fail, go again. Um, but yeah,
the mentorship, that was probably the most valuable thing to me because I think if this whole thing
didn't happen and we weren't here talking right now, I probably would have gotten so annoyed at the
time and I would have just went, Nope, not for me. Yeah. Well, I think, and I think there was, um,
just from like a technical perspective, I think there we've worked through a couple like quality
vulnerability things and stuff like that. But, but to be honest, a lot of, because I think you've been
focused on being a pen tester for so long, I think you had a really good base of like technical knowledge
and ability to approach these targets. So a lot of it was more like, yeah, you're on the right track,
stick at it, keep at it, keep at it, spend more time on this target, dive deeper here.
This isn't a real lead. This is a real lead, you know, that sort of thing. Um, so I think it's a lot
easier just from a mentor perspective with you to, to point people in the right direction because,
or to point you in the right direction because, you know, you already had a sense for what an attack
vector looks like and that sort of thing. Yeah. Yeah. I think the other side of it, putting the mental
and like softer skills away, the technical piece was quite valuable because the client side stuff,
that is very much your jam. Like everyone knows that everyone who listens knows that. And that
isn't an area for me where I ever deep dived in and spent the time to craft and learn, because I think
there's a lot of intricacies and it's very much an alive and living ecosystem, which changes a lot as
browsers change and so on. Um, and I just sort of abandoned that. And I think we've touched upon this
later, I think, but traditional pen testing and bearing in mind, I started 10 years ago and all the
advice I got was very light network, hard and traditional pen test experience. Um, it goes against
that style of bug hunting. I think in my opinion, because there's a lot of focused around
traditional attack vectors more from a network perspective. And I'm speaking from experience
when I tried to break in, but equally with web app, there's more around the traditional like
web app, hardcore stuff rather than more client side focus. Yeah. And I think Jason, I think it might
have been Jason Haddick's touched upon this before. And I think it's because a lot of the material,
I mean, it's getting better now, but a lot of the material traditionally that was built around this
was around that traditional like web app hacking stuff and not much focus on JavaScript analysis
or anything like that. So I think that's been really, for me, incredibly valuable to like
balance my attributes in all areas of hacking, if you see what I mean.
Yeah. Yeah. And it's, it's, it's all too easy to go one, one direction or the other. Right. And I think
to become a balanced hacker, you really have to often intentionally balance, rebalance yourself. Right.
Mm-hmm . And I, I often find myself moving too much in the client side direction and being like,
you know, yeah. And, and, and because at the end of the day, I mean, unless your application has a
specifically, um, intense, uh, threat model, uh, most of the time, what you're going to achieve with
client side stuff is, is a high, right. Uh, you know, at max. Um, and while a high feels great and
keeps the, keep the pockets loaded, uh, you know, it, it isn't as fun as popping like a critical where you're just
you know, dumping everyone's PII and it's like, you know, you got access to everything. Right.
Um, so I know for me, you know, just, and it's funny because, uh, these mentorship sessions have
also turned into like, I don't know, like group therapy, like bug hunter group therapy where I'm
like, Hey Brandon, guess what I did? Guess what I learned about myself this past week, you know?
And like, and like, and so it's good to sit down and like talk about stuff. Right. Because, um,
um, I also get to regurgitate these, these lessons that I'm like realizing for myself as well, but it,
it's, it's, it's far too easy to leverage in one direction or the other. Right. Um, and so I think
one of the things that I want to try to work on in, in Q4 of this year and going into 2025 is,
is like swinging back onto that server side realm and using the client side stuff to inform the way
that I attack the server side more directly. Um, rather than getting caught up in the weeds of like,
Oh, that looks like a weird sanitization or that looks like a weird little, you know,
code flow that they've got there. Um, so. Yeah. I would say we've done a few hack alongs as well
for people that aren't aware. And it has been interesting because you like, when I blink,
you've got like dev tools open, like straight away, like, and you start going down that flow of getting
familiar with an app, which I never used to really follow or have much knowledge on.
And that for me was really interesting to see, because if you're not, uh, predominantly doing
much client side hacking or have much clients like bugs that isn't intuitive at first, but then as you
start to use like the dev dev tools and doing some like dynamic analysis to inform your hunt and inform
your testing going forward, that's where it starts to get quite interesting. But that's one thing that
definitely stood out to me when we done our first hack along was I blinked and like dev tools was like,
and you're like, break point, break point, break point. I love it, man. It is great. And it really
does inform a lot. Um, yeah, when I think that's a takeaway and we'll, we'll go to takeaways from this
past live hacking event as well, because, uh, Brandon, dude, Brandon, I have to say, man, you had me
sweating there for a little bit at this last live hack event, because, um, you know, I was like, okay,
you know, this is cool. My mentee, you know, is going to a live hacking event. Like, this is fun.
And then like, you messaged me like one hour into the event. You're like, dude, I just popped a crit.
And I'm like, oh shit, is this how we're going to start? Like, am I going to, I got to hustle. So I,
I, um, you know, for a little while I was sweating there about whether my mentee was going to outperform
me and if the, if I was going to need to write something for you to become, become the mentee now.
Um, but, uh, it, it turned out quite great. So we'll, we'll, we'll come back to some of the LHE,
um, takeaways, but definitely this time around, one of the, one of the big ones for me that that's
relevant to this was, yeah, that whole aspect of, um, and I think this might be like a nice axiom,
like something that, that we should have, like one of the takeaways from previous pods that I've always
held with me is, is Jason Haddix's quote on, on recon. The purpose of recon is to find more apps
to hack. Right. And I think, um, one of the axioms that I would like to, you know, sort of propose out
there is that the client side can really, really be useful in, in determining, in informing the way that
you, you make assumptions about the server side. Um, and I missed that, this event, man, and it hurts
me because, um, another hacker, uh, you know, just found some really crazy stuff with that. And
after I sat down and reviewed some of the, um, the, the material, uh, some of the bones with them,
um, something really, really clear to me stuck out. And I was like, Oh, what have I done?
Um, that feedback that is, yeah, we keep, we keep saying that we'll go back to it, but we keep talking
about it, but let's just do it, man. Let's just do it. I don't know. Yeah, let's do it. Okay. Continue.
Go ahead. But that feedback that you get in that LHE context, where you're able to see what other
people are hacking and get that immediate, Oh, I miss that. Or, Oh, okay. I maybe didn't spot that
is just so like, you don't, you don't get that really anywhere else in bug bounty, unless you
collab. And even if you do collab, you don't get it to that extent because people have literally spent
three weeks on the same sort of areas as you have in the same weird contexts. And then you can talk
about it and see what they found. And that for me, it just felt like another piece of the puzzle
falling into place. And I was like, this is great. Why I was not here before. Yeah. It's such, it's
such high feedback, right? Like, like you think about the way we, we are traditionally educated,
right? You know, you, you go, you study, you, you take an exam. Imagine if you just never got a grade.
You never got, they, no one ever told you if you had the answers right or if you had the answers wrong.
Right. And, and, and so I think, you know, live hacking events sort of is the closest we can get
as hackers to getting a grade on our work. Because if you, if you look at all the other
hackers around you that are extremely talented and you look at their work and you say, okay,
well, probably between the combination of the 50 of us, you know, somebody, you know, somebody found
pretty much everything there is to find, but then, then you do it again the next time. And then there's
still more things to find, um, which is just the sort of mind boggling, um, thing that happens
with these live hacking events. So. And man, just Franz Rosen, by the way, like every time,
every time it just, it doesn't seem, it just doesn't, whatever he's stacking in his head,
fundamentally do not stack in mine. Yeah. I don't, how does he extrapolate the,
he done some really cool stuff for this LHE and done a show and tell, but that's all we can say.
And it was great. Yeah, dude. It's, it's always amazing, man. I'm so glad you got to go and
experience it because it is really, um, it is really amazing. And I think for me, I, to see you
go through it and to see you be amazed by it, it renews it a little bit for me because it's become a
little bit of, um, like a, a normal thing for me. And then now when I hear you talking about it,
like, oh my gosh, you know, it really is amazing. So it does, it does make me, um,
make me realize that. Yeah. If you, if anybody has the opportunity to go to a live hacking event,
I would really take it regardless of, of the, uh, of the cost or whether it's, it's, you know,
how much work it takes or, or if you have to pay your own flight or pay your own hotel or whatever,
because the, uh, the opportunity to be around other hackers and see how they think about the
same application, it's pretty rare because it, in a pen test contest as well, like oftentimes
most you get is a pen test report from another company, or like maybe you get paired, if you're
lucky, you get paired with one other pen tester to like pair work on a project. Right. So it's,
it's so crazy to see more than two hackers hacking on one thing.
Well, this is it. And like the time constraints as well, I haven't ever looked at. So for the past
10 months, my bug bounty hunting has been incredibly broken up, like maybe two hours a day here, there,
whenever I can fit it in around my schedule. Um, and I managed to negotiate some time off work to focus
on this LHE this time around. So I got a somewhat unexpected invite through and I was like, I have to
try and make this work. You don't get this every day. Um, and being able to spend that much time on
the target and also have that feedback from other hackers. I feel like it levels you up so much more
and quite quickly in some ways because of that immediate feedback and being able to have
three weeks worth of context on the target. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, so what do you think about,
let me ask you this for the people that haven't experienced what it's like to be a full-time
hacker? What was that transition like the, the, the two to three hours? Like, were you experiencing
a lot of two to three hours to a full day, right? Or maybe, you know, a 12 hour day or whatever.
Right. So were you experiencing a lot of mental fatigue? How is your focus? You know, where, where,
where was the burnout? I, that's a leading question. Cause I know where that's going, but,
but, uh, yeah, hit me with that. It was interesting because where it was for such a long period,
that it was, it was like a roller coaster in a way. Um, and I think it started off very like energized,
really great. Like, yeah, that's bang, bang, bang, getting all these things. But then there are points
and the, when you're trying to hack something where you get stuck and usually when I get stuck,
I would have like a day or two in between of doing other stuff, then coming back to it and being
refreshing and going, ah, how didn't I see that before? Yeah. This time, however, when you're
going at it and you're looking at one target, having to like coach yourself through that mentally,
because it's very easy to fall into a hole and be like, oh, right. I'm so bad. I should be able to
get this. Why aren't I getting this? And you can sort of fall into this like pit of just despair
and you really need to try and avoid that or just get yourself out of it. So that was very
interesting for me because I hadn't ever really had that at all. Yeah. Spending that long on one
target. Dude, it's crazy how much of this podcast, which we, we really do try to orient towards
actionable bug bounty tips that we actually spend talking about mental, because I think bug bounty
is a particularly taxing, tasking mental thing, right? Like you, tasking, taxing. That's what I'm
trying to say. I'm like, I'm like, what am I, what am I trying to say here? Um, it's very taxing,
right? Like it takes a lot of energy. It takes, there's a lot of little like pits around there
that you can fall into and, and make a mistake. Um, and, and it's at every turn too. It's not just
when you're, when you're a beginner, right? It's as you're even, you know, as you're getting more
advanced, are you burning yourself out? If you're at the live hacking events, how do you deal with the
competition aspect? Um, yeah, it's, it is, it is really, it is really odd. Uh, but yeah. So, so,
I mean, there's definitely that mental aspect of it, right? Um, how was the, how were the,
the energy levels and, and how hard did you put yourself for this LHE?
Yeah. So I originally basically tried to burn all fuel in the tank and just go for it. And I put like
every aspect or tried to put every human aspect of my life on hold. And then I would like forget to
go to the gym because I was like halfway through like a chain of doing something incredible.
But that long-term really did work against me because just because you're in an LHE,
you still need to like do stuff and like refresh yourself. And I messaged you and I was like,
how's everything going? And you were like, well, I'm sort of being less productive now. So I'm going
to take like half a day off. And for me, I was trying to brute force through that period. And I was
like, no, we, we, we're going to keep finding more bugs. We've got to keep pushing. And then when I
spoke to you, I realized that it probably wasn't the right approach because with hindsight, looking back,
that really didn't work with me. It worked against me.
And I should have just taken the break time to refresh and go for it. And I feel like I was
spending between minimum seven, between seven to 12 hours a day, some days on the target,
trying to really peel it back and understand the context, which was great. But again, you need breaks,
man. Like just because you're in an LHE, you don't turn into Superman or something. I mean,
some people do, but I certainly do. Yeah. I feel that man. Yeah. And I think,
you know, in retrospect, when we had our conversation, um, about the intensity and, and what my,
my advice was, you know, for you going into the live hacking event, a lot of what we spent our time on
was like, you know, make sure you're trying to get other, other aspects of your life on lock,
right? Like, you know, get, get all your tasks around the house done, get, get your house clean,
you know, take your girlfriend out for a couple of dates, you know, that sort of thing. Communicate
with loved ones, uh, you know, try to, try to reduce your task load as much as you can for the
live hacking event and then sort of lock in and focus. But then there's also this, this reverse
aspect of like, as you're, as you're pushing, as you're going hard, um, you know, you have to do that
self care piece. And it's, it's also really inspiring for me to hear you say like, oh,
I forgot about all these human aspects. Like, I think this is a quote from you from, from our chats.
I forgot about all these human aspects, like eating and going to the gym. And I often forget about
eating, but I often don't think about going to the gym as like a human aspect, but it really is. And,
and, and it's funny, you know, you use that, that specific piece, because I think the gym is one of
those first things that, that goes for me. And like, if I, if I don't do it first thing in the
morning, right, it's not getting done that day for sure. Like if I even sit down at my computer,
I'm going to blink and it's going to be five o'clock and I'm at your six o'clock, seven o'clock,
I'm going to be exhausted. And then I'm, I'm not going to do it. You know?
I feel like it's one of them things as well. Like once you get it done, you get so much of an ROI on it,
just get it done because you feel good. It sets the time for the rest of the day.
You can smash this target, whatever you're looking at. And it just works. Whereas when you're,
or where I find myself in the LHE, I was very much in the mindset of, oh, if I'm not hacking,
there's someone else globally that is, which might mean we do. And it just fell into this like
horrible, like tsunami of cascading thoughts of if I'm not hacking someone else's. And once I got
myself out of it and just focused on hacking, like doing good hacking, but also doing other
things as well, I felt a lot more comfortable and just had a lot more fun as well.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. Wow. Okay. So there's, there's a, it's a lot, man. What did you, what did
you think about my, what did you think about the results of my advice for you to stick to a specific
portion of the application for the whole duration of the event? Because I know that there are some
people that, that jump around and try to attack every little piece of scope. I don't know how
Franz consistently finds crits on both targets, uh, in multi-target events. I just don't get it.
Um, but what is your, what is your thought on, on that, that methodology?
Yeah. So for me, it most definitely works. And I feel like with LHE and targets in general, there is
somewhat of a meta approach depending on the target. And for this one, instead of focusing
on an individual application, I'm more focused on the ecosystem that the application resided in,
because there's a lot of interconnected components and different APIs, different applications, which had
like their own, um, authorization, their own permissions, but yet they depended on each other
and dependent on these permissions, which were set in other applications. And for me, I focused a lot on
the ecosystem of my specific, uh, area, which I focus on, which done really, really well because on a
target like this, you can unlock a lot. And I feel like that lended itself really well to a target like
this. Um, but that approach definitely worked because I was able to peel back the layers and
get into places where people would either not think to go to, or they would have gotten bored and not
have even bothered trying to go that deep. So there was a lot of attack surface, which felt relatively
unseen, which was quite nice in my context. Yeah. I think with some of these bigger programs too,
um, obviously there's, there's a lot of hackers on the bigger programs and in bigger scope on the bigger
programs. Right. But, um, if you can weasel your way into, you know, just one or two layers deeper
than the normal hacker goes, there's really a lot of, a lot of results to be found there. Um, so spending
some time unlocking scope, I think is really important. And, and I think the, I like your term ecosystem
hacking where you're not necessarily focusing on one, on one, you know, app, but a ecosystem of apps
that sort of integrate together, um, and trying to get it in such a configured state where those apps,
unlock different, different pieces of each other and give you access to deeper, deeper, deeper scope.
I think that's, I think that's probably pretty widely applicable, but it's definitely pretty
applicable for Amazon because the, the, the, the target is public, so we can be, we can be, uh,
public about that. But, um, yeah, I think that's definitely the case.
Yeah. The, the ecosystem approach did work well. And when I feel like when you start looking at a
target, you get a feel for the different integrations and if they offer documentation,
read the documentation. And I just feel like when there's so many different apps and APIs that depend so
heavily on each other, but implement completely different access controls built on completely
different technologies, there's going to be a lot of different contexts which reside in each
and discrepancies across them. And I massively tried to profit off that and it worked.
Yeah. Yeah. So I want to take a turn here and, um, and go back to your LHG experience.
I just, just spending time with you in, in Vegas, um, when you weren't competing at the live hacking
events, I saw, um, how powerful of a networker you are. And, uh, this, the, one of the reasons you
got invited to this live hacking event, I imagine was you were plus one, not only by me, but by several
other hackers that you've met, um, uh, you know, in Vegas and, and talk to about the Buggun ecosystem.
Um, and so, I mean, I don't, I don't even know how to phrase this question. I mean, do you have advice
relating to that or is it just, uh, like something that, that you do instinctually that, um, has paid
off really well for you across these, these couple interactions?
Yeah, that's interesting. I think for me, it feels very natural and instinctual. It doesn't,
I don't, it doesn't require effort as such. I genuinely enjoy speaking to people. And like a lot of the
connections I made in Vegas, which I attended as a guest, not as a hacker, um, I made some really
good friends and like Greg Sunday, um, loads and loads of people. I just would literally go up to
someone and be like, Hey, what bugs did you find? Or can you show me some bugs and stuff like that?
That's exactly what I was going to say, man. I was going to say, like, do you ask the technical
questions? Cause I think people, despite what you would think 99% of the people in this industry
are love to talk about their bugs, right? That's like a flattering question. Right.
And so have people responded well to that? Very well, very well. And I think when the LHE
environment, what I find very interesting about it is that it's quite competitive in the sense that
there's a leaderboard. And then when someone gets a pair, there's a ding and everyone just like turned
around, like they're programmed. I was definitely programmed by the end of the LHE. Um, but the sense
of community and like collaboration and helping people out, that is like a very, very good piece
of the whole scene that you don't really get much of anywhere else when you're hunting or when you're
hunting. And I don't think, and just going up to people and asking about their bugs or like what
they're hacking on. I literally didn't get a single person be like, no, stop talking to me. Who are you?
Everyone's very welcoming. Very, very nice. And for me, that's what made my Vegas experience,
I think, or one of the things that made the Vegas experience. And I feel like that's what made me
want to get onto the LHE scene so much more than I already did because it just felt so welcoming.
And so it just, it was good. It's crazy, man. I think over the course of my entire bug bounty career,
I've been doing this since 2017. Right. So, so seven years. Um, I think I've only had somebody
say like, no, I don't want to talk about my bugs. Like, like maybe three times over that whole,
that whole course of time. Um, and so it's definitely, it's definitely very rare. And it's
also something that, that made me, um, you know, feel very comfortable starting this podcast. Cause I was
like, you know what, people love to talk about this, you know, they love to talk about their bugs
because it's something we're all passionate about in general. Right. Um, and I definitely have had
people say like, okay, well, it's different that, uh, you know, going on a podcast where thousands
and thousands of people listen every week and, and, you know, talk about my bugs rather than,
you know, just, Hey, Justin, yeah, check this out, you know, because it's, it's a difference in
distribution. Right. But, um, I think in general, I think, I think that's absolutely the case.
Um, all right, let, let, let me, let me look here back at a better at our doc real quick. Um,
yeah, I think we're good on the live hacking event stuff. Did you have anything else you wanted to
add to that whole, that whole flow? No, um, how was organization for you? Or I don't know what is
wrong with me today or organizing, how was, how was organizing all of the, um, all of the data that
you got? Cause you spent a very long time on, on one target for this event, right? This is actually
kind of a long event. Um, so yeah. Well, what was that like? And did you use your notes slash,
you know, different burp files or whatever? Yeah, absolutely. So for people that don't know me,
but Justin knows this very well, if I'm not taking notes and I mean, really good notes,
I am as close to useless as one can get. I need to, I just have to take notes. Otherwise it doesn't get
done or it gets forgotten about. And for me, for the whole LHE, I made a lot of notes and a lot of
contextual base notes and even voice notes as well. So I could just jump back into it when I was going
the next day, or if there was something that I really needed to stick that I didn't want to forget.
And for the entire time I was hacking remote, fantastic notes were going well. I was using them.
I was ticking things off attack vectors, bang, river in person.
I was just the, the mental energy it took me to like focus and just get on and try and do that.
I don't know why it just wasn't working. I think it might be like quite ADHD because there's so much
stuff going on, so many hackers and like collabs and like other people's bugs. That just went straight
out the window. That's a great point, man. It is, it is actually a very different skill set to hack with,
with people in person, um, than at home. Right. I think it's very distracting. It's very hard to actually
sit down at the live hacking event itself and hack. Um, because there is such social, there's, there's that
social presence where you'd be like, Oh, I, I so rarely get to see X, Y, Z, you know, I want to go talk to them.
Um, but also so many distractions around. Um, and I think that's why a lot of times there's,
there's that extra aspect of they, they put in this, this, uh, bonus of best, uh, bug on the event
day, right. Because they want hackers to continue trying to collaborate and hack together rather than
just kind of, you know, screwing around while they're there, you know, on, on event. But, um,
I think there, there, the inverse is also true. There are some hackers, some hackers,
Oh, X, Z, Z, Z, Z that, um, goes to the live hacking event and just somehow enters cosmic mode.
And, and just like, like when they're around their, their people, they just become this like hacking
God and always find a critical at the event on the event day somehow, or like at the night before in the
hotel at 3 AM or something like that. Um, so it's weird how different hackers respond differently to that
pressure. Yeah, man. That's, I, that I don't think that's ever going to be me. I hate to call it out
now, but I don't think that's me. I'm very much notes, tick it off attack vectors very much. I need
silence just to properly get into things and to get into my like workflow. Um, but with that being said,
when you're with other hackers at the LHG, it brings an entirely different set of opportunities
to collab on, which are equally as powerful because you have many different skill sets,
people with their own niches, lots of different contexts as well, and understandings, and that
can come together and do some really, really cool collabs and really cool bugs.
Yeah. Yeah. I agree with that, man. There's, there's definitely, there's definitely both sides of that.
I think it, I think it does take practice as well. I know, I know Nogli is another guy that often
finds something, you know, at the event and day of the event. And I would not really think that,
that he would be one of those guys, you know, Nogli, I know you're listening, but he often,
you know, goes to these events is like, you know, let's party, man. You know, like, but,
but then also he somehow rolls up to the hotel and opens up his laptop is like, look at this SRF.
That's like one little tidbit away from being exploitable. And somebody is like, just, just,
just do this. And then it's like, crit, crit, you know, like, and so it's great. It's great. So
that collaboration piece definitely, I don't know that it fully counteracts the ability to sit down
and like focus and, and get deep in, and have your notes, but, um, it definitely is a stroke in the
other direction. For sure. And I think it definitely depends on what type of hack you are and what
personality as well. I think that's another big thing as well, and bug bounty and LHE is you get to see
how people's personalities and how they interact and how they hack really has a massive play.
Because as you said, some people can just lock in and find some intense things where me, for example,
I was just, it was more effort trying to put my laptop password in, in itself than just trying to
open up birth and hack something on the day. So yeah, it's interesting to see, really interesting.
I'll throw this out there for the listener base as well. And it's something that I think I've
mentioned to you in the past, but one of the things I've, I've learned over years of going to the live
hacking events is in order to be a good collaborator, you really have to take your,
your co-collaborator, you know, the person you're collaborating with their attack factors or their
ideas or their things that they think are sketchy really seriously, more seriously than you would
probably think you should. Um, cause for me, you know, somebody will come up to me and be like,
Hey Justin, this is sketchy. And I'm like, I'll look at it and I'll be like, you know, for whatever
reason, this just doesn't hit me as sketchy or, or like, it's, it's not something that I would normally
spend a bunch of time on. Right. And then, and so I'm like, in the beginning, I was like, Oh, okay,
cool. You know? And I'd look at it for a second. And when, as soon as my brain said, ah, this is not
really sketchy, I would, I would put it away. Right. And I'd be like, Oh, okay. Yeah. I don't
really think that's, that's worth anything. Right. But then as I, as I had the experience time and time
again, of those people actually popping the thing that I didn't think was sketchy, I started to realize,
Hey, you know, Justin's, Justin's sketchiness radar is not completely, you know, locked in.
Right. I am not thinking everything is, is sketchy. That is sketchy and I'm missing things that, that,
that are there. Right. Um, and so I think even if you don't think it's a good finding, if you
respect the hacker that you are, are working with and you, you believe them to have a skillset that
you don't, then it's very important to take those, those leads seriously and really throw everything
you've got at them because, um, that difference in exploitation experience or difference in your,
your spidey senses, so to speak for, for that end point might be exactly the combination that's
needed to get that bug to pop as long as you give it a chance. Right. Does that make sense?
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, sure. I know. I know. I'm, I, I went, I went into full,
full mentor mode there for a second, but I think that's, I think that's a valuable one as well.
Yeah, it absolutely is because as we said earlier, everyone has their own skillset. Everyone, I mean,
a lot of people specialize in very niche things as well. So if something comes to your plate,
it's probably good to look at it and try and peel it back and see what they're seeing.
Mm. Mm. For sure.
Hey guys, our sponsor Project Discovery has dropped a new tool in collaboration with Google's own
Mandiant team called TLD Finder. Okay. Picture the sub finder, but for top level domains. Need I say
any more? Check it out. So let's, let's say we've, we've covered the live hacking events stuff a little
bit. We're done it backwards. Yeah. So Richard, I'm so sorry, because he's going to have to go in
here and timestamp this video and he's going to be like mentorship, LHE, mentorship, LHE. But let's,
let's swing back around to what has made you go from essentially zero successful experience in bug bounty at
the beginning of this year to what are you in like 13th or something out of like a hundred at this
last live hacking event. So a really remarkable performance. And, and a couple of the things we
had on here was what, how you choose targets and what you choose to do with those targets. So can you
talk a little bit about what your experience has been with that and, and how you, how you pick the
targets you go for and how you approach them? For sure. So when I'm looking at a target,
it, I try and pick things, which, and I have a list really, if I need to like buy something or if I
need something new or a subscription, I will look to see if there's a bug bounty program for the thing
I'm trying to buy, if there's a competitor I can use, which has a bug bounty program and I'll purposely
buy it from them. So I can walk through the flow in its entirety and buy something and almost get like
a two form or maybe even a freebie because it just makes so much sense to do. I'm going to buy it
anyway. So I might as well try and get some like additional experience or exposure to it if I can hack
it. So why not? And that's been pretty good. Um, and has unlocked a lot of attack surface for me.
And the other thing as well is what services do you currently use or can you start using similar to
the first point, which gives you one an edge on a target or two has a bug bounty program in itself.
So do you already pay for something, which is an integration for a target, which you have been
looking at, for example, is quite powerful and can unlock a lot of attack surface. And the reason why I
started these two things is because it almost like flows into your day to day life. You don't need
to go out of the way to buy something else or learn something else. You're already familiar with it or
you need to do it anyway. So it sort of makes sense and there's less resistance there. And the other thing
as well is in terms of region and where you reside, what can you, are you from the UK? Are you from the US?
Yes. What services can you unlock or what attack surface is unique and geographically exclusive to
you? Because I guess we'll touch upon it shortly, but I've had a lot of success in unlocking a lot of
hard to unlock areas, uh, purely because of the attack, well, the unlock complexity to get there in
the first place. Yeah. I, I, I kind of mentioned this a little bit, um, yesterday in the, in the talk that
I gave for the critical thinkers, but I have this theory on, on bug bounty that a lot of that we should
try to maximize, um, what I call the attack vector value, which is a function of the impact of this
specific attack vector. So what, what would you achieve if you were able to pull off this attack,
um, uh, times the, uh, probability of that attack, uh, attack actually succeeding. Okay. Is there,
is there like a, uh, is this a really a long shot at my, like, you know, dropping a command injection
prompt into like a, you know, logging endpoint or something like that, Franz, um, uh, divide divided by
the friction, um, to, to actually try that attack vector. Um, it, and so I, I think that that friction
component is really, is really the most interesting variable in that equation. Um, because the,
the friction piece, it can really, it can really save you from dupes. It can see, it can get you
exclusive scope. It can get you access to things that pen testers don't even get access to because
anybody who's been a pen tester consultant knows that when you roll up to a pen test, they're not
handing you a fully seated account. They're not handing you a, you know, a credit card you can use
to like buy the stuff behind the paywall, right? You're pretty much having the same thing that you have
access to as a bug bounty hunter. So if, if you don't have access to it, then the pen tester probably
didn't as well. So there's, there might be code living behind these, these little, um, paywalls
or location gates or whatever that, uh, that nobody has ever assessed. Um, and so that, that definitely,
that definitely unlocks some, some exclusive scope. And I think you found that at least what I've
observed is that sometimes you can go really hard on, on the parts of the scope that are
more accessible. And then when you move into those regionally locked things or paywall locked things,
all of a sudden everything just seems to work and it just gets easier. Um, which I think is really
encouraging as well, right? Because it's like, uh, you're not going up against this really, this really
hardened thing anymore. You've kind of found the hack to getting access to the sweet spot.
Mm. And I think that's one piece of advice I'll give to part-time hunters as well, which I'm
in hindsight, I'm quite happy. It didn't bother me. If you aren't full-time hunting and you don't have
much time to hunt or as much as you would like putting in an hour, two hours to go through that
flow and go through the very annoying process of signing up to something or configuring your account
to support five different types of flows, putting that investment in will probably pay off around 90%
of the time at some point. And you will dig something up. You just have to put that investment
in initially, which is what puts a lot of people off from doing it in the first place.
Mm. Mm. Yeah. It's hard. I like your, I like your tip though, of, of actually intentionally
unlocking scope for yourself with the products you, you, you buy. So it's not like I'm a hacker. I'm
sitting here thinking, okay, what do I hack? And then I see a product and I'm like, all right,
I'll just pay the money and buy that product and do the hack. Right. That's great. That's the,
that's the, you know, we've got that little Christian. I'm gonna, I'm gonna ask my video
editor to try to put this up on the screen. There's like the, the galaxy brain meme, right? The
small brain is like, you know, public scope stuff. The, the, the middle brain is like, you know,
oh, I'm paying for services. Right. You know, cause I'm a hacker. And then the, the galaxy brain is like,
really, I'm gonna, you know, go in and use the services that I have and, and, and, or intentionally
buy a service that has a bug bounty program for personal use, um, and make that a part of my
product selection. I don't know how he's going to fit that into a little thing, but.
Yeah. Sorry, mate. Yeah. Sorry. Sorry, Christian.
But, um, but I really liked that idea. And I, I, I've actually heard, I think it was Ben Naham
sex say this one time where he was like, yeah, I use this credit card. And I was like,
you know, you know, like just, just talking about credit card point hacking. I was like,
oh, this one really gives, you know, more flexible points and is really, you know, helpful. And he's
like, yeah, but that one doesn't have a bug bounty program. And I'm like, damn, that's true, man. If
you find like one bug, right, that is way better than all these points that I'm talking about. Right. So
intentionally making a product selection. For your personal use surrounding whether
something has a bug bounty program or not, not only pays dividends from a security perspective,
but also can pay actual dividends for you to get bounties. That's, that's great.
Literally. Yeah. I really like that.
Let me ask you this. So I guess you've had experience as a pen tester before going into bug bounty.
But what, what vulnerability classes have you, have you found to be most fruitful for you going from
beginner to LHE and, and then what vulnerability classes have you recently said, wow, this is
something that I wasn't, I wasn't looking for quite as much that I really should have been investing it.
So originally I think a lot of defaults and because of the amount of them there are,
there's a lot of excess broken access control. So I focus on them as my bread and butter and
that was my plan originally. But as I started peeling back and getting more familiar with targets,
a lot of logic-y type bugs as well kept cropping up. Um, but XSS, there's so many
everywhere that I recommend everyone to at least have them on your checklist somewhere to look.
But that's primarily where I started off. And then I went to Vegas and I attended Ben
the harm sex talk and he'd done a talk on SSRF and the talk was really good. I had some workshops in
there as well, all good stuff. And not that the techniques or anything new to me, but I had the
very, very harsh realization of why aren't I looking for SSRF? So talk was on SSRF.
And I sat there and I couldn't answer it. And I felt a bit silly because I just thought
there's no reason for me not to look for this. I have experience exploiting it in the past in a
pen test context. I just never bothered looking for it. So I took that away and I was all right,
okay, let's try and find some SSRF. And then it's a three weeks solid. I think it was
I train, I escalated three SSRFs into RCEs with Alex Chapman for three weeks. I was like,
one a week, which was incredible. And all headless browser exploitation, obviously that's Alex's jam.
But yeah, it just occurred to me, like if you have experience or some competitive edge around,
whether it be a target or a run class, don't disregard that because that's knowledge and
experience you can very easily put to use with the right mindset when approaching a target.
That was my biggest takeaway. This extends to industry as well, right? Like if you,
before you were a hacker have experience in whatever industry, the financing industry,
the construction industry, you know, the pharmaceutical industry, right? There are
almost certainly bug bounty programs out there that will utilize those terms or the requirements of that,
you know, field, the specific knowledge of that field, which is really, really helpful for you and
gives you a competitive edge. That's something that, that me, you know, as somebody who's been forced to
look at so many targets because of live hacking events, like it became a little bit less important
to me because I'm like, well, you know, if, if, if hacker one or bug crowd or wherever is going to just
point me at these targets, I got to be able to hack it. But you know, when I'm in my off time,
when I'm, when I'm not hacking off for these live hacking events, you know, working on targets where
I have, you know, industry specific knowledge, uh, could be fun. So I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna
see, man, maybe, uh, maybe there's some real estate, um, some real estate websites that I can go hack or
something like that. I can tell you right now I have, I can list some off which are private, but you most
definitely have access to them. There's a few, I know there's a few. Huh? Huh? I hadn't, I hadn't
really, I hadn't really thought about that. Um, so to come back to what you said though, you mentioned
a checklist and I know that you are very structured and I don't know that we've actually talked about
this, but I know that you're very structured that you take really good notes. Um, do you actually use
a vuln class checklist or are you, is your checklist mostly like attack vector ideation? Then that goes on
the checklist and then I'm checking those off one by one. Yeah. So when I approach a target where I've
had previous experience, pen testing and have like a base grounding on every, not every, but most phone
classes, I use a threat model approach on targets. So I go on the application, sign up, unlock everything
I possibly can, every single flow, go through everything. And then once I have that context as a
normal user, I'll start going through my burp history and playing around with the app. And when
I start peeling back the layers, I try and put down every single possible attack vector, no matter how
stupid it might sound, put down the attack vector, whether that be because the functionality is sketchy,
whether they're using a specific technology, whether the architecture lends itself to that, whatever it
might be. And my whole aim, when I'm going through this process, when I first approach a target is to
come up with as many attack vectors as humanly possible. So when I'm then hacking the target,
I have a massive list of inspiration. I can actually look at and just get really creative with
and tick off one by one. And the idea is that is a living breathing list document, which I can never
finish because the more familiar you get with something, the more ideas you should have. That's
my premise of why I do that and how I do it. And for me personally, with the way I work and needing
notes just to do any basic function of life in general, it's been quite successful. And you can pick back
up on the target, you can look at this list and go, okay, I didn't really try that last time,
but it's on my list. And then you can start going down that route. And I feel like if you are in a
part-time capacity and your time is quite sporadic and you can't just hit a target for two, three days
solid, that very much lends itself towards that. It's very, very useful. Yeah. Wow. I think this,
if I had to guess, obviously there's a lot of things going for you over this past 10 months that
have worked out well, but if I had to guess, I think this is probably the number one thing that
that has served you well is your, your dedication to attack vector ideation. And, and it's actually,
it's starting to click with me a little bit now, cause I've heard you talk about this time and time
again. And, um, I've even put it in some of these presentations that I've been doing, um, at DEF CON
and just yesterday for the critical thinkers, um, the importance of attack vector ideation and how pivotal
that is. Uh, I think it's probably the most underrated skill in, in bug bounty. Um, and it
seems like you have a good system for that. You, you, you, you start preloading this list, you get
this massive list, right? And then you, you know, you start working on the items and you allow those,
you allow your, your creativity to trigger and you allow yourself to go down different paths. And then
when you get to a dead end, a lot of people that aren't creating this massive list, they're just getting
stuck and they're saying, okay, well, I'm kind of, you know, that didn't pan out. I I'm, I'm, I don't
know where to go next, but, but for you, you've got this document where you say, all right, I don't
know where to go next, back to the next item on the list. And then you, you know, you start from there.
Um, that's really, that's really powerful, dude. I, I really, I really respect that approach. Is that
something that you think evolved from more, from more structured hacking? Like you, in the beginning,
you, you wanted to, you know, make sure you were, you were checking all the boxes with
the phone classes and stuff like that. Or is that just something, is that a function of the way that
you live your life with the note taking? So in the hacking context, I think that really started
when I started doing more code review type stuff, because to give everyone context, I don't have a
developer background, um, at all. I was very traditional blue team network administration,
SOC and then pen testing. So that development background, which a lot of hackers have, which
is incredibly useful to have, I didn't have. So when I, it all started when I tried to go for my OSWE
and I found it, it wasn't intuitive at first when I was approaching these code bases. And some of these
code bases were enterprise, small enterprise level. And I was just like, well, what have I been doing for
the last three hours? Like, where am I? Like, I don't even, I don't get where I am. Like what's,
what's been going on?
And so true.
Yeah. And, uh, I bet that's when I started coming up with the system. And when I tried to get into bug
bounty, I realized under the context I was doing it and the constraints I was doing it because in the
mornings I'd say, do stuff critical thinking. And then I'll do my main job. And then in the evenings,
I'll do bug hunting or it might be completely different. And in the mornings I'll be bug hunting
and whatever. I realized that that context switching is incredibly taxing mentally. It is incredibly
taxing and it's exhausting as well. And the idea of notes and applying that methodology when I'm
approaching a target takes a bit of that mental tax away because you can see your notes. You can
almost, it helps you prime yourself to get back into that. Right. Okay. This is what I'm going
for next.
Dude. I'm so glad I had you as a writer. Like, like this, this is the perfect guy for the writer,
the guy that like lives and breathes notes. Um, that's, that's awesome, dude. That, that,
that is really great. Um, yeah, I think, I think that is definitely one of the major components
that, that contributed to your success for sure. Um, all right, man, I think that is the end of
what we've, what we've got on this list here. Um, do you have any, oh, oh no, I almost forgot the bugs.
We got, we got to go, we got to go to the bugs. Um, all right, dude, you, you actually plopped some,
some three pretty solid ones on here. Um, so, so let's, let's start with this first one, ATO on,
on FinTech bank. Tell us how you pulled that off. Yeah. So this one was one of my first bugs ever
paid bugs and bug bounty. Um, it was my first one on hacker one and, um,
it was the first one was a crit. And after that I was very much like, I set the bar high for myself,
but then I also knew I wanted to like, keep that energy and keep going, which didn't pay me dividends.
The second time I didn't get a crit, but it was still good to get a crit first time anyway.
Um, so this one was good. It involved a lot of unlocking attack surface. Um, and I was trying
to basically peel back this target and understand what would hurt them and where some areas are,
which probably haven't been looked at as much. And in order to unlock this attack surface and really
get into the bottom of it, I ended up creating seven men. I might've been eight, actually real
bank accounts under my name and with different payment providers, which has hurt me a little
bit in the past 10 months. Um, it has hurt me quite a lot. I'm not going to lie. And there's
at one point I was even getting messages from like bank fraud teams. Like, who are you? Why are you
sending one penny with this nonsensical string? Who's Justin Gardner? Why has he sent you an
international payment?
Oh my gosh.
And, um, yeah, it was, it was an interesting experience, but that for me of unlocking the
attack surface and going through all that pain did pay off quite well. And it's all started with
really, it started before the bug hunting, but there's a lot of newer UK banks, which when you
get a payment, you can like respond back to someone with an emoji or a message. And I was thinking,
okay, cool functionality, maybe a little bit excessive. I don't know why that's necessary,
but how's that actually working? And some of these banks have a web app portion. So how is that rendered
and what are they letting through? Because emojis and like that's, that just had that little spidey
sense tingling. And throughout me approaching this target and performing this research,
I started the reason why I set up with so many different payment providers, not just bank accounts.
I wanted to understand what different providers allowed, what different character sets and how much
flexibility they're allowed to be sent with say a payment or a request or whatever it might be.
And that's where the magic happened. So primarily for EU now, but a lot of EU based fintech
related companies, I did something called the open banking API. And this is a open API spec that anyone
can look at online. And you can check which banks are compliant with which areas of the API. And it's
basically an API spec, which is defined for if a bank A wants to send money to bank B and you're both in
the EU or you're both UK based, this is what the API looks like.
Oh, so this is like a, like a B2B, like a business to business, or a bank to bank,
oh, bank to bank, B2B API. That's, that's pretty cool. And it's, it's standardized across all these
different banks. Yeah. So my understanding is it's primarily for EU based banks, because there's a
lot of, there's a lot of like functionality and all flows now where when you say send the payment,
you can log into your account and there's like this old flow and all the banks like know each
other, they're preselected. So you can just click your bank and then it takes you to the proper login
page and does a lot of the legwork for you. But the interesting part about this is there's a lot
of functionality there for one and two in the open banking spec, it tells you like what data types to
expect and how long the fields are and things like that. And compared to the open banking spec and what
was implemented, I found there was a lot of discrepancies in terms of what was allowed and
what wasn't. The one thing that was standardized across all of them, however, was a very strong
and limited reference in a payment. And that was hard set across all EU, UK providers. However,
when I was looking at what I can send and what I can't send, this is where I roped you in and why
I did get fraud, ringing their alarm bells and everyone like that. I wanted to look at how
international payments are handled right because open banking is more like EU to EU, what happened
with international. And equally with international banking, each bank has to support their local
character set, right? So like that could be anything, anything could end up in there really.
And that is where I managed to figure out that one of these inputs was vulnerable. And I essentially
used it to achieve account takeover through means of stored excess by sending a payment of like a penny to
grep me. And when they opened the payment, they go, who is this guy? Why is he sending me a penny?
I open it and bang, account takeover. Wow, dude, that's really solid. I'm going to be like a proud
dad for a second here and just highlight all of these amazing things that led to this bug. Okay.
First thing that just stood out to me so clearly was how far you went on this target. And I think we
talked about that, right? We were like, hey, you should really spend a lot of time on this target.
And you opened up seven different bank accounts in order to get access to all of this different
scope, right? When we talk about scope expansion, we're not just talking about, okay, swipe my card,
pay five bucks. Now I got access to the premium product, woohoo sort of thing. You went and you
filled out forms and you dealt with fraud emails and you damaged, I don't know what the UK equivalent
of your credit score is, but like- Oh man, it's on the floor. It's on the floor. I don't even look.
A bunch of stuff in order to achieve this, which is very dedicated. And then you're also,
the emoji piece was really interesting. The emoji piece and these different character sets,
because the way that you're looking at this situation, you have a spidey sense for what type
of data needs to be where and what kind of character sets need to be supported. So I thought that was
really a great example of actually thinking about and processing how data flows through applications,
right? And that's definitely a core skill that a lot of hackers need to understand is where that
data is flowing and what type of data we're dealing with. And then diving deep into that open banking API
and seeing, okay, well, for EU to EU, there's this, but then what happens internationally and thinking
about those edge cases in that scenario, it's just all of it comes together and culminates in an amazing
bug with great impact too. I mean, if you can send somebody money and then you take over their bank,
that is bad. So I just, I love all the different components of that that came together and how they
bounced off of each other. So, you know, I said, I gave a disclaimer. I'm proud. I'm happy with that.
Let me just give you a little round of applause there. Thank you very much.
It was, yeah, it was good. And I feel like fintech targets I almost lent into naturally
from prior testing experience and also after approaching this target and the amount of attack
surface that was there, I started to realize. And then when I discovered the open banking API spec and
all these discrepancies and things like that, it sort of was just, it just made sense for me that,
okay, there's a lot of weird things happening here, which probably weren't ever designed for
an emoji to end up in as a thank you back to the payment and things like that.
And yeah, it was, uh, when you start seeing them sort of things, it can be interesting to
peel them back and figure out why they're implemented and how they're implemented.
Yeah. A hundred percent, man. Well done. Well done. So I've obviously, I knew, I knew that story
because I played a little bit of a part in it, but, um, I'm not sure that I've actually heard these
other two. So hit me, hit me with this, uh, zero interaction ATO.
Yeah. So on one of the targets in the Hackerball Cup, I found an inherent design flaw by complete
accident at the time, but now it's being very much integrated into my methodology and something to
think about on other targets. Um, but it's this concept of understanding which endpoints expose
properties of an object that you're looking at and you're attacking. Um, and what I mean by this is
without trying to abstract it too much, if you have like a user object, for example, that you're
attacking in one way or another, I can take over excess noting down which endpoints throughout the
application ecosystem or entire ecosystem as a whole, which different endpoints expose,
which different properties of this same object and documenting them is very, very powerful because
objects can have different types, right? So when you look at a user object, for example, you can have
active, inactive, deleted, invited, revoked, bans, just one example. There's so many different states
and objects can live in depending on its context and being able to identify these endpoints, which
expose these properties of the object and hitting the same endpoints, but iterating the object through
a different context every time found some really, really creative bugs for me because there's endpoints,
for example, which were accessible to all users, which is completely normal behavior. They should be
accessible. That's the way it's designed. But when an object is in a very specific state, hitting that same
endpoint would expose like an invitation token, for example, which again, all users can see this, uh, endpoint,
but on this specific property, on this specific object, if you hit it when it's in the right state,
you might disclose something quite juicy in this context, an invitation token. And I found once I
realized this on a target in particular, I realized that this was pretty much everywhere. And the impact of
that was a lot of zero interaction ATO because you could just take over other users' accounts if they
were say invited or whatever state they're in because there are specific endpoints, not all, but specific
endpoints, which would expose these additional properties of that object and let anyone read them.
If that makes sense.
Yeah, no, that, that makes total sense. And I think you also see this often in, in the GraphQL world
as well. Like, like that is one of the, the, I don't know if this app was GraphQL or not, but it, you
know, you understanding what data types are on, what, what specific or what data types have what properties
and using different, um, queries and mutations and such to be able to, um, grab those properties out of these
specific objects that might be at different states. Um, definitely, definitely a powerful thing. And,
and it can affect, um, traditional APIs as well, like REST APIs. Um, and, and sometimes you'll even
see, I don't know if you've seen this one before, but, uh, some of these traditional APIs will have
sort of like GraphQL-esque functionality where you can add a query parameter that says like include or
something like that, and then name like a sub object or a sub property. And that will also be included in
the API response only if you put that in the query parameter. Right. Um, so, so those sorts of things
I think can really, and I like the way that you mix mixed that with state, state changes as well,
inviting, blocked, removed, you know, whatever. Um, as the, that data type, as that user type evolves,
um, you'll see different things in those different states.
Yeah, absolutely. And I feel like that's something, well, I think it was art
Gangel said that he finds a lot of like delete based broken access control and idols. And the
reason for that is when someone's testing this and say, you might have a typical flow of like using
authorize and just repeating requests, whatever in them operations, that's a one-time operation.
Once that's complete, you can't run it again. So therefore it's not going to show up as vulnerable,
but if you like, just drop that request entirely, then resend it when you're doing your testing.
That's why a lot of these like weird delete based and maybe more context based things
with these properties exist because that's a hole in a lot of hunters, um, scope. I think I've noticed
anyway. Yeah, absolutely. That that's, that's really interesting, man. I, I, I hadn't really figured
out the reason why that was the case where then a lot of delete idors made it through, but that makes,
that makes a lot of sense in those, those frameworks that will automatically do the access control
testing for you. And it reminds me of a bug that I found, um, within the past couple months, uh,
where there was an entity that, that you could modify explicitly. Right. Um, and so, you know,
the request just had that object's ID in it. Right. And one of those properties of that object was
the organization that the object belonged to. Right. Um, and you, if you tried to modify
somebody else's object with their, their entity, their organization ID in there, right. Um, then it
would fail and say, you're not allowed to do that. But if you put your organization ID in the body and
you referenced somebody else's object, right. Then not only would it allow you to modify it, but it would
steal it over to your organization. So, so now, so now the object is gone from their organization. It's in
your organization, which is, uh, affect to integrity. Right. Or, and in some case availability, depending on
the services that, that might break their whole setup. Um, but it also affects confidentiality. Right.
Because if you didn't modify all the properties of that object, you just modified a couple of them.
The, the remaining properties are still at the values that they were when they were in this,
this victim's organization. So you can leak data about that object as well. Um, so it really hits
the CIA triad really nicely. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. And so it turns into a really, really impactful
vulnerability. Um, so very good, man. All right, let's, let's jump to this next one. It's an SSRF. And,
and we know, we know big things come from SSRF for you lately. So.
Yeah. So as I touched upon earlier, I like to, on the targets that lend themselves to it. And I've
looked at a couple now, or I like to look at the ecosystem as a whole, rather than individual
components or applications of it. And there's some ecosystems and targets, which will offer something
like a developer based, um, service where you can test your own stuff and integrate into them, but
in like a test context and the test environment completely separate. Um, and equally more specifically,
I found that on one of these ecosystems that she allow you to tie and piggyback off the back of the
OAuth configuration. So you can use them to perform all of your light authentication and then you do
all the rest sort of thing. And when I was looking at this, um, ecosystem in particular, I realized that
there's a lot of assumptions made in other controls on hosts and endpoints that if something comes from
this host or something comes from this endpoint, it is safe, it is to be trusted. It is okay. Um,
without realizing in other parts of the ecosystem, there's ways that user input and developers can sign
up and also host something on these same endpoints and also piggyback off of this same config, which you
offer. And it was quite interesting because I was originally looking for SSRS in one area of the target.
And I couldn't quite get it because it was complaining about the host that was in use.
And I thought, okay, fair enough. Put it in my notes, come back to that later. Again, the notes come in useful.
Um, carried on looking at the, um, I will configuration and it turns out there's an area where you could
add your own redirect URI value to redirect to your own application at some point in their ecosystem and
at some point in the flow. So I was thinking, okay, what host does this reside on? And it started to
match up quite nicely. And I thought, okay, so now I can satisfy some of these validations
that they put in place of the host base part, right? When I was looking for SSRF that needs to
reside on this host. Um, you can't look at any other hosts apart from this host that is designed
business functionality. That's all you can do. And when I started playing around with OOLF,
um, if you play around with the code parameter, and if you put in like a complete nonsensical,
um, value in this code parameter, like blah, blah, blah, critical thinking, whatever it might be.
Um,
Critical, critical, critical.
Yeah. I did do that for my POC. Um, you can actually abuse that to go straight to the redirect
URI value and it just redirects you providing that the redirect URI value has actually been
whitelisted on the backend. So now the, the, are we talking about the response type or the, the,
is that what you're talking about? Sorry? Yes.
There is the response mode or response type. One of those two.
Yeah. Nice.
Whatever one is, you can put in a completely made up value and providing that the redirect URI value
has been whitelisted on the backend. It will just straight redirect you to that value. So I thought,
okay, that's interesting. And at this time, the puzzle pieces weren't really falling in place.
I was just pondering and thinking that is interesting. And then we got on a call and I was like,
there it is. And I tried it and it worked. So essentially what you could do is in this ecosystem,
you could sign up as a developer, host your own, or have some control over that. I will flow
on a host, which they used heavily for their own, um, input validation and essentially abuse that whole
flow to put a nonsensical, um, value in and hit the redirect URI every time. And using that approach,
I managed to get quite a lot of SSRS and it was like an inherent design flaw because I don't think
when the two teams didn't really talk when that architectural decision decision was made.
Um, and that was when I realized that spending time on a wider ecosystem and understanding all the
components of one can be incredibly useful because otherwise that would have been a dead end.
Yeah. Including the dev stuff, right? This is, this is one of the areas that I think is the most fruitful
for bug bounty stuff is going and registering with this specific platform as a integration partner or like
use their SDK or like, you know, there's, there's tons of, of mostly untouched stuff there because
people don't want to go, you know, down the rabbit hole of like, all right, now I got to go like set
up this website that like emulates this integration and set up this JS file and blah, blah, blah. And, um,
that used to be something that I would do, you know, just as like, okay, I'm going to do this because
I'm going to get deeper and like attack this specific portion of the scope. But now, dude,
it's so much easier with AI. You can just feed it. You can just feed it the page and be like, Hey,
generate the, um, you know, the client side requests to trigger this flow and it'll do it.
And I'm like, Oh my gosh, this is amazing. Um, but I, I think that that's, I think that's a really
good takeaway for, for the listeners of, of like looking at that, the ecosystem as a whole, like you're
talking about looking at the dev related stuff. And then I, I really liked this trick that, that you
mentioned of, of you weaponizing the OAuth flow to, to create an open redirect. Because if you,
like you said, I think it's, I think it's the response type, uh, because it would be response
type code, right? Um, yeah. So, so if you put some nonsensical value in the response type,
it will often just redirect back to the redirect URL, because that's the way to inform the host that was
initiating the OAuth flow that something failed. Right. So boom, you got an open redirect and
that's gotta be widely applicable in so many environments. Right. Yeah, absolutely. I feel
like, especially now all these integrations that exist and when you start looking at more ecosystem
based targets, and this is heavily used in FinTech as well. There's a lot of test environments,
test flows, test accounts, test data, all this sort of thing, all these sort of things, which
you can actually abuse to satisfy the requirements that some of their other defenses rely on in some
cases, because the hosts might be the same and maybe even the endpoints match up if they're checking that.
So it can be incredibly fruitful to go through and understand, okay, on, this is what I can set up.
This is where my endpoints, my inputs are and matching that up with production and the rest of that scope.
Yeah, dude, as I'm thinking about this, I'm thinking, I'm thinking I need to go try some stuff
right now, actually, because I'm, I think there might be a way for me to exploit a bug that I've
been wanting to exploit for a very long time. So I think we're going to call that a pod, man. I think
we're going to call that a pod. You got anything else you want to say at the end or am I free to go?
That's all good. That's all good. That's all good. Go and have fun.
Did you see my eyes just expand there for a second? I'm like,
I got to go. I got to go. All right. That's the pod. Peace, everybody.
Peace.
And that's a wrap on this episode of Critical Thinking. Thanks so much for listening. And if you
want more Critical Thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord. Join the discord. There's
lots of great conversations and chats going on over there. And if you want to support the show,
there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hackalongs,
exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.